-I think you would be
great at this,
'cause you're
a very good singer.
In this challenge,
you're gonna get a song title
in a completely different
musical genre.
Then, you're gonna have
to sing that song in that style.
-Right, I've seen you
do this before.
-Let's see what song you get.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We could do [Indistinct].
"7 Rings."
-Ooh, wow.
-Doo-wop?
-And a doo-wop version.
"7 Rings" by Ariana Grande.
Adam, what do you think?
You think you can do
a Doo-wop version?
-Oh, we gonna make it right
for you, Kate.
Let's do it.
-All right, go for it, buddy.
-Okay.
-Kate Hudson.
Whenever you're ready, bud.
-You ready?
-Hold on. Hold on. Hello?
Whoo!
♪ Doo-wop ♪
♪ Dooooooowoooop ♪
-Whoo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-All right, let's do this.
All right, let's put me on
A-sharp -- A-sharp.
-♪ Doo-wop, doo-wop, doo-wop ♪
-♪ Breakfast at Tiffany's
and bottles of bubbles ♪
♪ Girls with tattoos
who like getting in trouble ♪
♪ Lashes and diamonds
and ATM machines ♪
-♪ Money machine ♪
♪ I buy myself all
of my favorite things ♪
♪ I've been through
some bad stuff ♪
♪ I should be a sad bitch ♪
♪ Who woulda thought it would
turn me into a savage? ♪
♪ I'd rather be tied up
with calls and not strings ♪
♪ Calls and not strings ♪
♪ I write my own checks like
I write what I sing, yeah ♪
♪ My wrist, stop watchin',
my neck is flossy ♪
♪ Make big deposits,
my gloss is poppin' ♪
♪ You like my hair? ♪
♪ Gee, thanks, just bought it ♪
♪ I see it, I like it,
I want it, I got it ♪
♪ Seven rings ♪
♪ Seven rings, seven rings ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Are you kidding me?!
Are you joking me?!
How do you know how to do that?
Oh, my God! How?!